if we think about something like 2/3
power we could view this as taking three
twos and multiplying them together so
two times two times two or equivalently
we could say well this is the same thing
as taking a 1 and then multiplying it by
2 3 times so let's see let's just go
with this definition right over here and
this of course is going to be equal to 8
now what would based on this definition
I just did what would 2 to the second
power be well this would be 1 times 2
twice so 1 times 2 times 2 which of
course would be equal to 4
what would 2 to the first power be well
that would be 1 and we would multiply it
by 1/2 1 times 2 which of course is
equal to 2 now let's ask ourself an
interesting question based on this
definition of what an exponent is what
would 2 to the 0th power be and
encourage you to just think about that a
little bit if you were the mathematics
community how would you define 2 to the
0 power so it's consistent with
everything that we just saw well the way
we just talked about it we just said
exponentiation is you start with the 1
and you multiply it by the base zero
times so we're not going to multiply it
by any two so we're just going to be
left with a 1 so does this make sense
that 2 to the 0 power is equal to 1
let's think about it another way let's
think about another way let's do it
let's do a different base now that was
with 2 but let's say we have I don't
know let's say we have 3 and I could say
you know 3 to the 4th power that's 3
times 3 times 3 times 3 which is going
to be equal to 81 actually let me just
write that down let me just write down
that this is going to be equal to 81 if
I said 3 to the third power that's 3
times 3 times 3 which is 27 3 to the
second power is equal to 9 3 to the
first power is equal to 3 do you notice
a pattern every time we decrease the
exponent here by 1 so we want 3 to the
fourth and now we go through the third
what happened what happened to the value
well going from 81 to 27 we divided by
three and that makes sense because we're
multiplying by one less three so we
divide by three to go from 81 to 27 we
divide by three again if our exponent
goes down by one and we divide by three
again when we go from nine to three
divided by three so based on this what
do you think three to the zero power
should be well the pattern is every time
we decrease our exponent by one we
divide by the base and so we should
divide by three again would be the logic
if we follow that pattern and so three
divided by three you would get us one
again so I know it might seem a little
bit counterintuitive that something to
the zeroth power is going to be equal to
one but this is how the mathematics
community has defined it because it
actually makes a lot of sense
either if you view an exponent as taking
a 1 and multiplying it by the base the
exponent number of times so I'm going to
multiply one by two three times or if
you just follow this pattern that look
start you know every time you decrease
the exponent by one you're going to be
dividing by the base either of those
would get you to the conclusion that 2
to the 0 power is 1 or 3 to the 0 power
is 1 or frankly any number to the 0
power is 1
so any number so if I have any number
let's say I have some number a to the 0
power this is going to be equal to 1 I
have an interesting question for you and
let's just say this is this is the case
when a does not equal 0 I'll leave you a
little bit of a puzzle for you to think
about what do you think 0 to the zeroth
power what should to the 0 power be and
what's interesting what's interesting
about 0 to the 0 power is you'll get a
different answer if you use this
technique versus if you use this
technique right over here this technique
would actually get you to being 1 while
this technique would have you divided by
0 which we don't know how to do anyway
I'll leave you there to ponder the
mysteries
zero to the zeroth power